joe biden à la tête des états unis est
ce une bonne nouvelle pour la france
après quatre ans de présidence trump les
relations entre les deux pays seront
forcément différente
washington et paris ont connu des
désaccords notamment sur l'otan le
nucléaire iranien
la taxation des gars femmes la défense
des droits fondamentaux ou la lutte
contre le terrorisme
sur ce dernier point le chef de l'état
français emmanuel macron a souhaité plus
d'implication des troupes américaines ou
sahel lors de ses voeux aux armées
par notre présence dans cette région
nous sommes un partenaire indispensable
de nos alliés américains et je suis sûr
que dans les prochaines semaines la
nouvelle administration aura à prendre
des décisions structurantes qui
marqueront un réengagement une prise de
conscience de la nature de la lutte
contre le terrorisme et pour la
stabilité de la région
il nous faudra continuer dans les mois
qui viennent avec des états unis
d'amérique réengager dans le
multilatéralisme je l'espère est engagé
sur plusieurs lieux de conflits nous
faudra convaincre de nos choix de leur
pertinence dans la durée j'y suis
profondément attaché un détail n'a pas
échappé aux français le secrétaire
d'état a nommé par joe biden s'appelle
tony blinken
un francophone qui a vécu plusieurs
années à paris difficile de dire pour
l'instant si cela embellira de manière
significative les relations franco
américaines
mais parmi les premiers signes concrets
d'apaisement dubaï donne a promis de
ramener les états unis dans l'accord de
paris sur le climat dont donald trump
s'était retiré à peine élu en 2017